[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to professor
came at North Carolina State University
is visiting us here today UC San Diego
and as generously agreed to be a podcast
gas on the our Christy Clark center for
human imagination into the impossible
podcast and I thank you very much for
doing that
are you following not too long on the
heels of your former PhD advisor a
professor Paul Steinhardt Princeton
University so first I wanted to ask you
what brings you to San Diego today about
my Dark Matter research I drove down
from Los Angeles because my I've been
visiting Nikhil and my family in that
area okay Audino you're from mark
familier oh great good get to tunnels
and what is it like in North Carolina me
been there you were in Australia right
before him yeah let's not change my mind
it's been different I was away from you
guys for eight years I was in England
for three years and I just got back a
year a little over a year ago so it's
been an adjustment do the macula States
yeah something that my health care is
better but yeah it's good the the new
job is great so I'm in the physics
department assistant professor of
business center track and I'm also part
of this new initiative they're called
the leadership and public science
cluster and it's all about getting
together people who do some kind of
public science so citizen science open
science eyes communication and having us
work together and initiatives and kind
of to see what we can do to
make new connections between science is
that NC state initiative or is that part
of it you know the mission of the state
of North Carolina
it's an unceasing thing so it's funded
through like provost office dedicated
mission to to do more public science
that we do will there be a research
component Lee researching how the public
interacts with science or how to improve
how we communicate so there's that
cluster so it's a question there's five
of us in the public lands cluster so
there are a couple of projects within
the cluster that we're all sort of
contributing to in some way you know
that have a connection with that so
we've looked at things like how getting
people into science might effectively
their identity with science for example
as as as scientists now so we have a few
things proposed to try to kind of try
new things and see see if we can really
get some qualitative data yeah I've seen
a couple of citizen science initiatives
lately
we actually were involved with one
related to the new horizons project you
know personally I wondered how much of
it was sort of public relations for the
scientist versus you know actually
citizen science you know participation
what would in your mother some of the
more successful examples of public's
public engagement in science where
scientists are actually benefiting from
interaction with the public and
vice-versa
to do is a great example because they
they you can sign up to go and look at
galaxies from the survey that their
comment and it's not a minister and you
just have a bunch of sources and you
tell it like what peda galaxy looks like
it might be if there's anything weird
about it and then they use that data to
to look at like populations of galaxies
and how they evolve over time and they
found some like weird new phenomenon
that way and yeah and so it's it's been
this fantastic like data set that people
have directly contributed to and you
know and it's not just like you know
just sort of give a classification
people get involved in like learning
about the science and and occasionally
find something really interesting and
they can essentially be like part of
that discovery year it's been anything
to watch how that goes
that's great yeah yeah we have [ __ ]
Simmons was here for a long time that's
faculty currently the yeah the question
of how to engage scientists I mean for a
long time the american association of
variable star observers was an
organization that actually have a lot of
publications and amateurs would get
involved in in the science that they
yeah was more is less than citizen
science are really passionate amateur
astronomers so it is sort of as sort of
a new age
I guess study at home was another
accepting successful example in some
lines right yeah yeah well let's do this
differently because you just let your
computer do a thing right actually
interact with it directly I think the
many things like galaxies who are
effective because you actually are like
looking at the data yourself you're
actually like interacting with making
judgments and learning about it in a way
that just blending your processing times
not just not doing when you were a young
person what sorts of scientific interest
were most close to your heart do you
think it was was it astronomy always as
a little person no I got into it through
physics astronomy so I must have to it's
not great yes understatement that makes
it so it was quite good about a hundred
years ago yeah so I didn't you know I
didn't grow up like serious nice guy or
whatever mom but I was always interested
in Mike how things work and you know I
would take art electronics and figure
out what was going on but them back
together and the little things and and
do experiments is I think I was always
interested in that kind of thing and at
some point like I was really into
interested in things like science
fiction at some point I discovered like
people like Stephen Hawking and Paul
Davies were writing books about like
time and space and time travel and you
know black holes and stuff like that no
just got really excited about this topic
so which is
lectures being in LA was great because
they're people come through and get
talks and I went to you know I saw
Stephen Hawking speech that Stephen
Hawking speak a couple of times when I
was young and so that was really great
and in the real research yeah and so I
think by the time I was about ten years
old those reading brief history of time
and I was like I want to I want to do
with this personalities and I kind of
that he was about the cosmologists
I was like okay I want to be a
pathologist son so that's what I want to
do so it was very much through the sort
of physics cosmology side rather than
through strata me
and you think I'm Stephen Hawking have
undertaken a project which was very near
a year Stephen Hawking's career in life
legacy which is to write a popular
science book and I understand money but
what you're saying now and then from
other things I've read and research
about you but he was a big influence on
here and it's interesting I went back
and read the brief history of time after
he died as a homage to his life and work
and it's funny because you look at and
reading it there are so many passages
where he does the dangerous thing that
cosmologies do it was just a predict
what's going to be discovered in the
near future and most if not all of what
he was predicting turned out not to be
currently in favor just [ __ ] that
happened inside but you in your book as
I understand it and I'd like you to
describe it if you in mind you're
venturing way out on the limb in many
ways because you're not predicting how
things will be in a decade or you know
after you get tenure and beyond but
you're talking about the Brio of the
future on a explain that sort of
listeners yes so I've been thinking
about writing books for a while and like
what kind of topic I wanted to cover and
one of it one of the things I most enjoy
talking about in terms of like public
talks in stuff like that is the end of
the universe like how it's all going to
end what's going to happen in different
weird ways for the others and and so I
thought that would be a really good
topic for a book because there are lots
of books about the beginning of the
universe and there aren't very many
about the end and it's it's a fun place
it's a fun place to look at right now
because there's there's a
of research in that area but it's not
certain you know so we don't really know
what's going to happen other beautiful
possibilities that are still in play so
what I'm doing is writing about five
different possible ends for the universe
and what it would look like and what
would happen and how like what evidence
we have for or against those
possibilities and how we're going to
figure it out you know in the next few
decades or whatever so right now we're
in the office that was once occupied by
the late great Jeffery Burbage who with
his very formidable
life market beverage were some of the
leading founders of healthy second
faster businessman space sciences here
and as you know he didn't believe the
universe really had a big bang origin
and sort of went to his grave I hosted
many cosmologists such as yourself or
coming here and he would be polite but
through at the same time through these
great men and women I wonder how do you
deal with because you must get a lot of
kind of ideas thrown at you shall we say
that are a little bit not in the
mainstream how do you how do you
approach it how do you treat something
which may sound crazy or may sound
definitely unorthodox but sometimes
great ideas come from those directions
how do you how do you approach kind of
me going out of the mainstream and or do
you think that's important to consider
things that aren't you know kind of not
been heard well so for example you know
the dominant paradigm a very early
universe cosmology is inflation and
there are some people your former thesis
advisor included who conjecture that not
only are such hypotheses wrong and
wrongheaded they're actually bad for
science and there should be other
alternatives and like yet they seem to
have a monopoly on the way that
physicists think such to the extent that
that it becomes hard for young people to
get jobs in the field or get attention
in the field who may not be carrying the
torch and or in the mainstream so is the
same the same thing happens say in you
know thinking about the end of the
universe as I said your book is very
different some about the elements about
the end or there is the same level of
controversy surrounding
happened in the deep future and if so
have you what's your reaction for those
concepts I don't know I mean you see
have you seen people not able to get
jobs because they worked on that
Parramatta cosmology or some that I've
heard claims back yeah I've heard claim
is that people in sin death and it's
very difficult to get jobs and you know
and I've had this debate with all as
well to say that you know well it's it's
one thing to do something completely new
and but you should also understand
everything about what comes before even
if it disagrees with your hypothesis I
mean to take a classic example I mean
the steady state for many years was was
felt to be much more palatable because
he could be disproved it could be
falsified whereas the Big Bang seemed
like oh every time there's an
observation things would change to match
those observations including you know
the the expansion rate of the universe
you know going changing community or the
temperature of the sand each engine that
they hired the specific expansion rate
it just so far as a hot dense early
universe so that was as soon as we found
the CIB that was very clear yeah so I
guess the the claimant that I've heard
is that you know especially with the and
we actually talked about this on the
podcast not too long ago you know when
you have when you have kind of the
instantaneous ability to to maybe maybe
but a unkindly attack an idea or a
salient idea before the theorists or
thinker has a chance to really flush it
out you know they're just presenting
things I think you know the claim is
sometimes you need a little bit of
funding to work through an alternative
idea before you actually you know
already take it public but if you don't
agree with someone I don't think of
people like Sabine Houston Thunder who's
make me to claim that at least in
particle physics there seems to be this
this obsession with this the quest for
mathematical elegance and beauty and
that according to her at least is this
sort of responsible for a little bit of
a herd mentality and importance of those
things I don't know so much if that's
true end of the universe cosmology but
but I guess getting back to the original
question do you what do you see as the
as the role that you know kind of
because there seems to be multiple
possibilities for what you're describing
in there five different possible endings
I mean would you ascribe a probability
one of those being more correct less
correct I'm powerful in some sense or
less I mean I think there there are yeah
there are varying levels of evidence for
different possibilities the same with
any area of physics
I think the in my experience in mine
field what what tends to happen is that
any time a new idea is put forward its
scrutinized and it should be and it
scrutinize very strongly and if it
doesn't fit the data as well as the
previous model then it's put aside and
if at some point it fits the data better
then people gradually shift over to the
new paradigm and that's that seems to be
how it's been going and within the
course of my career anyway and the areas
I work in and I think that's perfectly
fine and healthy um I think they're
always going to be people who get really
caught up in a bad idea and try and like
tweak things to fit that notion but I
haven't found like I didn't know I I
think that some of the worry is about
like oh no it's a herd mentality are are
really just the fact that you know
people take a practical approach to we
have a lot of evidence for the small
there are things to test about it let's
continue testing this model this other
idea that isn't fully fleshed out that's
just kind of like oh I have this notion
you don't know what to do with that and
if it doesn't fit the data as well you
don't know what you like then it doesn't
make sense to to put a huge amount of
effort into that until it's fleshed out
or until it does actually give you a
better model you know so so I I'm sure
there are people who are irrational
about this stuff but I think that
sometimes those kinds of worries get a
little bit like exaggerated and yeah
like by people who fear that they're
being unfairly
by the establishment amendment I mean
based on a lot of the emails I get a lot
of people who feel fairly treated by the
establishment in terms of like I have
this idea why isn't anybody you know
aging yeah and usually it's because it's
not something that's like easy to test
or not something that's fully developed
and so you know you can only spend so
much of your time
working on something where it's it's not
a clear straightforward question getting
back to the end of the universe stuff I
mean in my book I'm looking at five
different possibilities one of them is
the Big Crunch which is probably not
going to happen in the sense that the
universe is accelerating expansion it
seems very difficult for it to turn
around and fall back again but I talk
about it because it's something that was
historically it looked a lot more
plausible than the other alternatives
and now we have better data that shows
us only not going to happen but we can't
say for certain when it dark energy
might not sort of turn around and become
something else and you know you present
it as a possibility and then you know I
talk about heat death I talk about the
big rip few things as things where we
don't know for sure and here's what it
would look like and here's the data that
would support it or not and here are
reasons why people are interested in it
you know so I don't say like this is the
one that's definitely gonna happen no
point do I do that
all right but but I do talk about where
we're finding data for and how we
evaluate these theories and why why we
might shift from one to another as being
the more favored model so you know right
now I think that the consensus view is
that probably we're heading towards the
heat depth which is where a dark energy
just makes the universe really really
big and everything dilutes and you end
up with a dark empty cold universe right
and that just kind of persists and keep
paying your taxes because it's already
happening if you
boy did you know you're already sort of
tenuous yeah but in our regional
university how are stars that I have
another few million years um but anyway
so you get so that's that's considered
the sort of current default hypothesis
because it seems like a very clear exact
extrapolation from what's happening now
and it's a model that we basically can
understand you know dark energy being a
constant we don't know why it would be a
cosmological constant but if it's very
simple in the equations and that's dark
energy where the universe just expands
expands and eventually you get a heat up
and then I talk about for example the
big rip where you have a kind of dark
energy that's a little bit more exotic
and gets more powerful over time and
sort of rips apart galaxies and planets
and people and all of that and that's
kind of a more sort of exciting you know
we there reason that's why theorists are
not as excited about it one of them is
it's a little bit more complicated than
a comical concept another is that there
are sort of issues with energy
conditions that such so such a kind of
field or whatever would have so but in
terms of the data it doesn't it doesn't
fit the data less well and sometimes if
it's better so you know there are
different ways to look at these things
and at the moment we can't fully
distinguish between those two
possibilities but it makes sense the
larger community was gonna say well this
one has Hueber sort of weird theoretical
problems with it so let's stick with
this for now it seems a more palatable
ism yeah exactly so that's that's
certainly sensible way to approach it
and again to commend you on viewing what
Yogi Berra
before that's not to do and that you
know it's very difficult to make
predictions especially about the future
and the end of the universe
being the most most distant future one
could imagine so when I call it sitting
with a couple of questions one was
submitted by a fan of the podcast and
she asked me to ask you what are some of
the ways that we can encourage more
young
especially women to enter into STEM
fields and especially perhaps physics
and astronomy I mean I'm not a
sociologist so a better person asked
would be a sociologist somebody that
actually studies this topic I think that
for women and you know especially for
old enough color and for other people of
color and for gender and sexual
minorities for people with disabilities
people with you know mental health
issues or not be neurotypical also there
all sorts of ways in which the
environment of academia and other
academics can be costal to people and I
think that the important thing is to
really produce those Affairs to change
the attitude of academia of just society
in general toward people who don't the
stereotype of what a scientist is I
think those things are much more
important than you know painting a
circuit or pink or whatever these kinds
of things that people try and do because
I think that people who are interested
in science that they want to be
pleurotus in science and aren't
discouraged from doing science because
of various kinds of societal barriers so
I think that it's important to address
those things and it's important to make
sure the people who are in positions of
power and positions of privilege are
working to reduce those barriers mm-hmm
so with the final question irrespective
of you know which particular you know
subgroups just in general as an educator
yourself one of things I'm most
fascinated with and one of the things
that always comes up on the podcast with
all our guests is is the notion of
imagination and curiosity and I wonder
you know if you think or how you think
of this question of teaching curiosity
or teaching imagination is it something
you think is innate it sounds like you
were driven from a pretty young age with
the
curiosity and the thirst understand
physics in the universe but can it be
something that's taught or is it you
know like being a physician or something
like that or craft or is it something
that is less tangible and there's no in
your opinion you know direct path
depending on to teach the subject or the
ability to be curious or used one's
imagination in the way that's effective
towards increasing scientific knowledge
I mean I think definitely curiosity can
be taught and encouraged and the way
that we teach physics and other Sciences
can be more exploratory I think those
are all important goals and there's a
whole body of literature about you know
the pedagogy about how we teach science
and how we teach it in order to
encourage people to be active learners
and to get really engaged with the
subject and you know again a lot of it
is just not discouraging people and you
know I mean I was fortunate that when I
was growing up my family was very
supportive of me you know tinkering all
the time and I'm going to lectures and
to the observatory and just exploring
what I was interested in and I also had
the time and the freedom to do that in a
way that a lot of people don't always
have you know I was fortunate enough to
have the you know financial ability to
go to a summer camp without space you
know a lot of people can't do that so I
think that you know when when people are
not encumbered by other sort of
pressures and when people are encouraged
to follow their passions I think that
you you've got a lot more ability for
people to explore their creativity and I
think that it can't be creativity can be
taught as a you know in if we change how
we talk about how people do science if
we change how we introduce people to
science I think that that's a big part
of that but but you know I think a lot
of for a lot of these things it's a
matter of giving people the time and
space to really explore their true
all right okay well I want to close with
with ways that you can find forecaster
Katie Mack online are the ways people
can find out more about you and your
work
yeah so my website is Esther Katie calm
I'm on Twitter as Esther Katie I'm on
Facebook at facebook.com slash Esther
Indian on the Minster grandma's academic
Nomad because aspirin ad was taken and
it was true I remember trying to you
know assigned as a homework problem to
calculate KT max average velocity you
know because you were always picturing
yourself on the plane you know yeah but
it sounds like you've settled down a
little bit more at least a little East
Coast
although you weren't it's nice to have a
chance to kind of stay at my place for a
while absolutely great well thank you so
much for being here enjoying us me into
the impossible podcast with today's
special guest professor came back and
look forward to future discoveries and
especially to your book next year Thanks
[Music]